New York City Mayor Mike Bloomberg to
time nanny the month in 2009's nanny of
the year is back to save us from our
choices yet again in order to promote
breastfeeding the mayor has ordered all
public city hospitals to lock up the
free samples of baby formula new mothers
who are unable to breastfeed or simply
choose not to can still request the
formula but only after enduring a
lecture from a hospital employee on the
benefits of the boom over the bottle
this helpful guilt trip will be added to
the already required viewing of the
terrifying shaken baby syndrome video
that all new parents must watch before
their baby can be discharged from the
city hospital still the new law has its
supporters like Susan burger a certified
lactation consultant with a PhD in
nutritional sciences from Cornell I
think that there's been a lot of
misrepresentation really what the law is
all about is giving the mothers who
choose to breastfeed better choices it's
so paternalistic to have the mayor say
the formula has to be locked up you have
to get a lecture breastfeeding is
superior we know that but why does the
mayor of New York City have to dictate
that to new mothers well I don't know
that he's necessarily dictating that to
new mothers I think this is something
that within the hospital system they're
trying to put into place a better method
for making sure that hospital employees
are not violating the rights of the
breastfed mothers by giving it out to
women who don't really need it or wanted
or giving them bad advice so the real
intent of that law is to protect
breastfeeding mothers to be able to have
their freedom of choice to breastfeed
not to prevent someone who decides that
they want a formula feed from being able
to have access to that formula you know
women should be encouraged to not use
drugs and not have c-sections that does
happen it just because I think it should
be so doesn't mean it should be along
great but that's you're assuming that
because women are being given
information that the information is
going to be bad
and you're assuming that because they're
being given this information that
they're going to have the choice taken
away and that's not necessarily the case
so women Joyce is diminished though as
as opposed to being more of an open
choice just asking for something and
getting it but now there are conditions
for accessing that time wait but it's
pretty minimal conditions for accessing
but it starts as minimal and then it
only gets bigger and bigger bigger it
starts as a soda ban and then you know
all of a sudden you can't buy cheese in
the grocery store well that hasn't
happened yet and by the way Mayor
Bloomberg should ban breast milk because
it is so high in sugar and fat but we
all know that restaurant that's supposed
to be high in sugar for brain growth
always gonna do yes but it's not the
same type of sugar right lactose is what
like is needed by the human brains to be
able to grow properly all right Susan
burger thank you so much for your
welcome for reason TV I'm Kennedy
you